This first song we're gonna do, Mason and
I wrote this summer. This is probably
only the third time we played it, so if
we mess it up,
please have mercy.
My name is Brynn Elliott. I live in
Currier House. I'm studying philosophy
and I am class of 2018 so I'm a junior.
(Music)
What I study often informs my songwriting. I think
that's kind of one of the biggest
reasons that I'm at college, at Harvard,
is so that I can sort of build up a bank
of knowledge for songwriting. I was
really interested in the humanities
in general. I remember the first English
class I ever took was, like, the most
amazing thing to me and I started
getting interested in philosophy
because I loved asking questions.
(Music)
The way I describe being a student musician is
just sort of like being an athlete, so I
travel on the weekends to play different
shows, different gigs. I practice every
day, so it's also like being an athlete
where, you know, 2 – 3 hour practices just
music and listening the songs and just
kind of growing as a musician.
(Music)
I often procrastinate writing papers through writing songs.
This past weekend I was supposed to
write a paper on Spinoza's mind-body
problem and I just wrote a song instead.
I did write the paper but it was just rushed.
(Music)
I think the Harvard community definitely influences my
music because I'm around so many
interesting people every day with so
many interesting stories and human
perspectives. I think so much of writing
music and writing a song is about
getting into another person's story,
trying to use a collective unified human
voice and I think being here, being at
Harvard that's just, there are opportunities
to engage with that everywhere you go.
(Music)